So I went through some of
the symbolism of the unknown.
I want to go through some of the
symbolism that's associated with the known
today.
So give you some sense.
Flags are definitely patriarchal symbols.
There's their cultural symbols,
and here's some.
I'll just lay out every variety of terms.
And so that'll give you some indication
of the network of associations that's
associated with the symbol
of the dominance hierarchy.
Fundamentally,
culture,
Apple Linnaean control.
That's after Apollo,
the god Super Ego,
the conscious,
the king,
the patriarch,
the plow.
Cause the plow opens up the earth,
the Fallis Order and authority and
the crushing weight of tradition,
the wise old man and the tyrant dogma,
the day sky,
the country man,
the island,
the heights,
the ancestral spirits,
and the activity of the dead.
Now these symbolic realms
or are kind of there,
there's there
situationally transformable.
So if you look across cultures
very frequently in stories,
you see characters that exemplify
each of these categories,
but the characters can
shift to some degree.
For example,
so often if the story involves the ocean
and an island than the ocean will be
feminine in the island.
Will be masculine.
But if the story utilizes
an island and the air,
then the island will
be feminine in the air,
will be masculine.
So it isn't as if there's a one to one
correspondence between the entities in
the story and these
architectural categories
because their definition depends
on,
they can't be defined in isolation.
So it's,
it's,
it's sort of like does
this really stupid example,
but it's the best one I can
come up with at the moment.
If you're trying to interpret statistics,
you can't understand what
a given statistic means
unless you know the number of
people in the experiment,
the effect size and the probability that
that effect size is that at emerged at
a better than chance level.
Any of those pieces of information
without the other two are actually
meaningless.
And it's the same situation here.
You have to have the representation
of culture and you have to have the
representation of nature and you have
to have the representation of the
individual and then you
can figure out what's,
what entities are being used
in those different categories.
Even though there's some
similarity across stories,
which is partly why you could
actually understand stories,
right?
Because if there was no
similarity across them,
then you wouldn't be
able to understand them.
So,
um,
there some representations
of the great father.